[موسيقى]
بالنسبه الى سوريا هنا اتذكر جيدا تلك
المرحله علينا ان نعلم ان سحكوزي كانت
لديه التحفظات ذاتها التي كانت لدى شراكه
حيل بشار الاسد ايام جاك شيراك كانت
العلاقات صعبه تحسنت ما حافظ الاسد ولكن
بعد ذلك شعرنا ان بشار الاسد لا يفي
بالتزاماته حدث بعد التشنج بين بشار الاسد
وفرنسا وكذلك بين الاسد وبلدان الاخرى مثل
دول الخليج كان لدي ساكوزي مشروع كبير تحت
عنوان الاتحاد من اجل المتوسط من اجل
تحقيقه كان عليه ان يضم اليه كل البلدان
المعنيه
عن هذا الاتحاد حاول ساقوزي اي يعاود
الاتصال مع بشار الاسد لينجز مشروع
الاتحاد من اجل المتوسط بعد ذلك راينا ان
هناك بعض اذا مات التي لم يتم الايفاء بها
لاحقا وبعد الربيع العربي ايضا راينا كيف
تعامل بشار الاسد مع المعارضه وهنا تدهورت
العلاقات فصدرت مواقف فرنسيه معارضه ضد
الرئيس السوري
وهذا ما نراه اليوم في روسيا هذا الامر
يطرح الكثيره من المشكلات بالنسبه الى
خذلان الشعب السوري
لم ينجح في البدايه مع بشار الاسد لاجباره
على اتخاذ موقفا مختلفا اذا ما طالب شعبه
ولا اعتقد ان فرنسا كانت الدوله الوحيده
التي حاولت مع الاسد فالسلطات السعوديه
على ما اعتقد حاولت افهمه ان بعض الامور
لا يمكن ان تحدث وعليه الاستماع الى مطالب
الشعب عندما يكون المرء على راس الدوله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]